welcome back we are on problem number
13 right yeah 13 13 is what's on page
491 the price of a telephone was first
increased by 10
and then the new price was decreased by
25
the final price was what price of the
initial price okay
so
the price
final
is equal to
the initial price
price initial
so the price of a telephone the initial
price was increased by 10 percent
so when you increase something by 10
percent that's like by multiplying it by
1.1
right
you could say you know 1 plus 10 percent
or you know that's 1.1
and then
it was decreased by 25 well decreasing
something by 25
the same thing is multiplying by 0.75
why is that because that's 1 minus 0.25
right
and so this sets up our relationship
and so we just have to do some math what
is 1.1
or what is 0.75
times
one point one well one times is
seventy-five
zero seventy-five
five
minus eight and how many points do we
have the decimal point one two three so
three points so we have price final
is equal to price initial
times point eight
two five
and what do they say the final price was
what percent
of the initial price so that's it the
final price is 82.5 percent of the
initial price
82.5
and the main things you should realize
when you increase something by 10 that's
the equivalent of multiplying it by 1.1
and when you decrease something by 25
that's the same thing as multiplying it
by 0.75 and why because it's 1 minus
0.25 you're decreasing it by
25 percent and that is choice c
next problem number 14. this is what i
do every day in my job i work for hedge
fund and i'm always doing percentages so
image
invert colors
okay 14. i do other things don't think i
you know my entire livelihood is based
on just multiplying percentages but
a surprising fraction of it is
anyway
all right problem number 14. when the
other when the number w is multiplied by
four
the result is the same as when double
four is added to w okay so it's saying
when w is multiplied by four so four w
is the same thing as the result is when
w when 4 is added to w so it's the same
thing as w plus 4.
fair enough
what is the value of 3w
3w is equal to what well
subtract w from both sides of this
equation you get three w equals four
that might have been
the fastest problem we had to do right
we just solved it three w is equal to
four choice e
problem fifteen
the lengths of the sides of a right
triangle are consecutive even integers
fascinating and the length of the
shortest side is x looks like i'm going
to have to draw a triangle
in yellow
so this there it's a right triangle
it's a right triangle like that that
looks like a right triangle to me
and they say the consecutive even
integers
and the shortest side is x so let's say
this is x
consecutive even integers
so the next even integer is going to be
x plus 2
and then
the last integer
or the is going to be the hypotenuse the
next one right and this is going to have
to be x plus 4.
and they want to know what is x or or
what equation can be used to solve for x
well this is pythagorean theorem so we
just say this squared plus this square
is equal to this squared so
x squared
plus
x plus 2 squared is equal to
x plus 4 squared now let me see if any
of this is already there in any of the
choices x squared plus x plus 2 squared
is equal x plus 4 squared yeah it's
already there we didn't have to do any
simplifying this is choice c
and we are done
these problems are extremely fast to do
and the important realization is that
they're consecutive even integers right
so you add 2 each time and you just use
pythagorean theorem
next problem
problem
16.
if x is an integer greater than one so x
is an integer greater than one
and if
y
is equal to
x plus one over x
which of the following must be true
i like these
okay i'll write all the choices down two
and three
okay this first one says
y does not equal x the second one says
y is an integer
y integer
the last one says x y
is greater than
x squared
well let's think about it
do we know
well first of all do we know that y is
an integer
well no not really i mean we could i can
immediately find an x that
if x is equal to 2
x equals 2 then y is what it's 2 plus 1
half it's equal to 2 and a half so we
know y isn't an integer if x is an
integer y doesn't have to be 1. so we
know this is definitely not the case
now do we know for a fact
that y does not equal x well let's let's
play with this equation to see if we can
get it to a form that makes a little bit
more sense to us
so we know that x is greater than 1 or
that x does not equal 0
and obviously this would be undefined if
x equals 0. so let's multiply both sides
of this equation by x so we get x y
is equal to
x squared
plus
one
right
this all of a sudden looks fascinating
x y is equal to x squared plus one
so do we know immediately
that x y is greater
than
x squared
well sure no matter what x squared is
x square x y is going to be that number
plus 1 right and this term is always
going to be positive right
this is always going to be positive
there's no way you can get x squared
plus 1 if you're not dealing with
imaginary numbers that's going to be
negative so this whole thing is going to
be positive x is positive so if this is
positive x plus we also know that y is
going to be positive i don't know if
that helps but anyway
but we know that x
x
y is always 1 more than x squared so we
do know that x y is greater than x
squared so this is true
now let's see if we can show that y
has to not equal x
well let's think about it
no matter what x is
no matter what x is
y of x is going to be equal to some y is
going to be equal to some fraction
larger than x and as you get really
really really large x's that fraction
the difference is going to get smaller
right like you could try it on a
calculator if you put in you know it's
if x is five then y is five and
one-fifth
if x is five hundred
then
y is five hundred
and one five hundredth but no matter
what number you put in that's you know a
larger number than one
you're going to get a little bit left
over y is going to be just that little
bit fraction larger than x so we know
for a fact that y
is going to be not equal to x
and so this is also true
so choices 1
and 3 and that is choice d
and we are done this section because
there's only
16 problems as far as i can tell yep
only 16 problems actually i think we're
done all the math sections in this
test number two in the book i will see
you in the next test see you soon